bienvenidos de vuelta tenemos este
resorte verde que está pegado a una
pared y digamos que en este lugar vamos
a ponerlo aquí digamos que en esta
precisa posición que vamos a denotar por
el lugar pero digamos que ahí es en
donde naturalmente se encuentra el
resorte es decir el resorte a lo mejor
da vueltas y si no movemos el resorte
este punto amarillo debería estar aquí
en su estado natural o de reposo pero en
esta situación empuje al resorte y tiene
un desplazamiento digamos de equis
unidades es decir todo esto desde el
cero hasta el punto en donde se
encuentra la punta del resorte mide x
muy bien entonces tuvimos un
desplazamiento de x hacia la izquierda y
solo nos vamos a concentrar en la
magnitud en este vídeo no vamos a
centrarnos mucho en la dirección lo que
quiero hacer es pensar un poco o quizás
primero deberíamos graficar cuánta
fuerza hemos aplicado en di en distintos
puntos al ir comprimiendo el resorte así
que vamos a utilizar la gráfica para
calcular después
el trabajo utilizado en comprimir el
resorte muy bien entonces vamos poniendo
los ejes
digamos que aquí está el eje vertical
y tenemos el eje horizontal muy bien
entonces lo que vamos a graficar es en
el eje horizontal vamos a poner x x va a
ser nuestra variable de que tanto se ha
desplazado este este resorte y digamos
es hacia la izquierda verdad aquí está
el 0 y el x comienza a crecer hacia la
izquierda quizás esto es un poco
distinto a lo a lo convencional pero es
porque estamos justamente comprimiendo
nuestro resorte y aquí vamos a medir qué
tanto hemos comprimido este resorte
hacia la izquierda muy bien y en el en
el eje vertical vamos a poner la fuerza
que hemos utilizado y vamos a ponerle la
fuerza de compresión que hemos utilizado
para justamente comprimir este resorte
muy bien entonces lo que sabemos de la
ley de hook es lo siguiente que la
fuerza de restitución la fuerza de
restitución es menos la constante del
resorte por el desplazamiento que es x
verdad si nosotros queremos eso bueno la
fuerza de riis
va en dirección contraria hacia dónde
estamos comprimiendo verdad entonces
hacia donde comprimimos sería cada vez
es cada vez es nuestro desplazamiento
verdad y eso es porque nuestra fuerza de
compresión va justo en la dirección
hacia donde estamos comprimiendo
mientras que la fuerza de restitución va
en dirección contraria muy bien entonces
si nosotros queremos graficar la fuerza
de compresión pensem pensemos primero en
lo siguiente si este punto está casi en
el 0 es decir está muy cerquita del cero
entonces nuestra fuerza inicial que
sería pues no para para desplazar los
cero unidades necesitamos cero de fuerza
verdad porque ya está en su estado
natural entonces de aquí es de donde
partimos ahora pensemos que a lo mejor
nos desplazamos no sé un metro
un metro entonces a lo mejor aquí
estamos
un metro y si tenemos un metro cuál es
la fuerza pues sería acá por uno
entonces tendríamos que subir cada
unidad es verdad aquí sería acá
muy bien ahora qué pasaría si no tenemos
un metro si no tenemos dos metros
entonces si tenemos dos metros
multiplicamos por acá y la fuerza nos da
dos acá entonces duplicamos esto digamos
aquí está dos acá y cuando estamos en
dos metros aquí estamos en dos metros
entonces estamos en dos acá muy bien
digamos más o menos ahí entonces uno
puede ir observando que en realidad el
comportamiento de esta fuerza es una
línea es una línea y más o menos se ve
algo así
más o menos que pasa justo por estos
puntos muy bien y ahí tienen ustedes la
línea que describe cuál es la fuerza de
compresión que hay que utilizar para ir
desplazando x unidades de distancia
verdad ahí lo tienen entonces si lo
piensas bien digamos si la fuerza
inicial es muy grande este este resorte
va a acelerar mucho más rápido verdad
hasta que la fuerza de restitución
empiece a cobrar a cobrar este su parte
es verdad lo importante de aquí es que
la fuerza de compresión crece
proporcionalmente a la distancia y esto
se ve justamente porque la fuerza es una
ecuación lineal para la distancia verdad
es es proporcional a la distancia y por
eso es que se ve aquí esta línea muy
bien entonces sí nos sí sí ya vimos que
es una línea nos podemos preguntar cuál
es la pendiente cual es la pendiente de
esta línea
y uno fácilmente puede recordar y si no
te recomiendo que veas los vídeos de
geometría sobre líneas que si yo avanzo
una unidad vemos cuánto subimos y aquí
estamos en acá y llegamos a dos acá
entonces subimos acá y eso pasa para
cualquier par de puntos verdad está
proporción entre lo que avanzamos y lo
que subimos se conserva verdad
justamente es la pendiente la pendiente
la pendiente se define como el cociente
entre lo que subimos bueno el cociente
de lo que subimos entre lo que avanzamos
verdad y en este caso es la verdad que
entre uno es que esta es nuestra
pendiente para esta línea muy bien
entonces si nosotros queremos calcular
el trabajo que necesitamos para
comprimir hasta digamos algún punto x 0
digamos que aquí tenemos x 0 muy bien
aquí está x 0 y queremos ver si sí o
cuánto trabajo hay que aplicar ay cuánto
trabajo se requiere para comprimir este
resorte
una distancia x0 yo no puede recordar
que el trabajo se calcula como la fuerza
por la distancia que se recorre en la
dirección de esa fuerza verdad entonces
aquí tenemos nosotros justamente la
gráfica de la fuerza
tenemos la gráfica de la fuerza y
simplemente hay que multiplicar por la
distancia entonces por ejemplo si aquí
tenemos esta distancia multiplicamos por
la fuerza y nos da esta área verdad
porque sería distancia por la fuerza es
área de la base por la altura sería la
la base por la altura verdad si nosotros
queremos ver cuánto cuánto trabajo
utilizamos en mover de este punto azul a
este punto morado entonces nuevamente es
esta área verdad entonces uno puede
darse cuenta que a medida que queremos
ir calculando el trabajo a medida que
vamos avanzando lo que vamos haciendo es
calculando áreas de estos rectángulos y
que esencialmente estamos aproximando el
área debajo de esta recta
realmente lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular el área debajo de esta línea
hasta llegar a x0 verdad
tenemos que calcular el área que hay
debajo de esta línea y eso a lo mejor
para muchas personas ya les suena un
poco a cálculo integral verdad ahí ya
suena un poco a cálculo integral perdón
a cálculo integral estamos aproximando
el área con rectángulos entonces
realmente esto es es un poquito
tangencial al cálculo integral pero no
nos vamos a meter en eso porque el área
de esta figurita la podemos calcular
fácilmente si aquí tenemos x 0 cuál es
este punto este punto en realidad es x 0
como x 0 por cada verdad x 0 por cada x
que la fuerza es k por x y aquí la x
vale x 0 muy bien entonces el área de
este triángulo como es pues es base x
altura entonces el trabajo lo calculamos
como la base que es x 0 por la altura
y dividimos entre dos verdad tenemos el
área de un triángulo es un medio de la
base por la altura entonces tendremos un
medio por la base por la altura que es
x0 acá y esto quien es x 0 por x 0 es x0
cuadrada entonces tendremos un medio
tendremos un medio por x0 al cuadrado
por acá muy bien entonces esta es la
fórmula que ustedes deben recordar así
es como se calcula el trabajo que
realizamos para comprimir el resorte
hasta una distancia x0 y que de hecho si
ustedes se acuerdan bueno si ustedes ya
han visto cálculo integral esto es lo
mismo que la integral de cada equis de
cada equis de equis verdad pero no nos
vamos a clavar en el cálculo integral
esto fue algo muy sencillo porque
queremos calcular el área debajo de una
línea verdad entonces por ejemplo si
ustedes les dicen que tienen que la
constante del resorte es 10 y quieren
desplazar 5 metros entonces la fuerza o
el trabajo que ahora aquí coincide con
la energía potencial el trabajo
realizado y la energía potencial
coinciden entonces esto sería un medio
por x 0 al cuadrado que serían 25
por 10 que es nuestra constante de
nuestro resorte entonces tendremos 10
por 25 son 250 entre 2 son 125 y la
energía potencial se miden jules así
como el trabajo verdad el detalle aquí
es que si se dan cuenta este trabajo
solo depende de la posición por eso es
que esa energía potencial básicamente
esta ecuación es lo que tienes que
memorizar y bueno aunque es ideal que
sepan de dónde sale eso es realmente lo
importante y por eso es que hice este
vídeo esto calcula el trabajo que ha
realizado para comprimir el resorte y al
mismo tiempo coincide con la energía
potencial almacenada una vez que es
comprimido hasta ese punto o también
puede ser cuando lo estiramos verdad
depende de la dirección así que una vez
que ya sabes esto podemos hacer
problemas de energía potencial en
resortes que haré en el siguiente vídeo
nos vemos pronto